[Music]
pretty music welcome back to cbs
mornings over the past two years the
most serious effects of the covet
pandemic have happened mostly behind
closed doors or in private homes and
hospitals where more than eight hundred
thousand americans have died think about
that number for just a second and many
more have been sick this morning we have
the story of a mark of a remarkable
nurse who documented part of the
enormous human toll in photographs our
lead national correspondent david begno
is here and this really is remarkable is
a word to describe what this man has
done really powerful it was a privilege
to follow him
uh within the last week good morning to
all of you you know as you probably know
my team and i have been covering covert
since the start of the pandemic and
invariably wherever we are around the
country there's a nurse or a doctor who
will say to us
if only the public could see what we see
alan hawes gives us that chance
when alan hawes goes to work at the
medical university of south carolina in
charleston he brings with him a special
ability
a talent really that he uses when he
cares for the sickest of the sick covet
patients
he takes pictures
of what you and i would usually never
see because before he became a nurse 11
years ago he spent 23 years as a
newspaper photographer
and that gives him the ability to tell
the stories of these patients this is a
gentleman named ryan simpson we had to
send him emergently to our cardiac icu
and you all believe covid is what
damaged the heart so severely oh yeah
his heart was beating so fast
for many days
135 to 165.
and this is his wife sarah so this is
the first uh moment that she saw him
that day and was i think kind of taken
aback by all the people in the room as
they're preparing to take him to the
operating room so many frontline workers
have said to us
if only the public could see what we see
well alan hawes convinced the largest
hospital in south carolina to allow him
to give sight to what those caregivers
routinely see this is a woman who is
very sick she was with us for a long
long time and her family brought in this
prayer cloth the family wasn't able to
visit but this prayer cloth was sort of
their representative
and what happened to the lady she didn't
make it
his pictures document kovid's grip as it
tightens and he was totally there as you
can see
he's texting people on his cell phone
telling them what's going on but why did
you want to capture this i felt like i
knew where he was going and what
happened
this is what happened
so two days later
i walked in and
there he was
vaccinated he is unvaccinated
so you're now at a place if i'm hearing
you right where you're like
say levy it is what it is don't want to
get vaccinated wind up here i
have quite a few times
had a patient who's unvaccinated and
i'll think to myself
you did this to yourself
but that doesn't last long
it's
part of being a good nurse is having
empathy
once you hear the stories of some of our
patients from their family members you
can become a fan of that person and you
just know that they've made a bad
decision
you humanize them
yeah you're mad at them when they come
in the door and then you start to find
out who they are i've had some really
hard times with that i mean nurses are
broken right now emotionally are you
i feel
like i am yes
how long did you have to work over the
hospital to get permission to do this a
year and a half
yeah i think the time when i got
approval to to do the project i titled
my email public service project
and i think that's what made the
difference every time he gets permission
to photograph either from the patients
or their family members i think people
have a message that they want to get out
there the mother holding a picture of
the newborn she can't touch
the girlfriend who keeps a bedside
journal stephen james lavender you know
that i love you with all of my heart and
soul you better not ever leave me every
night i tell all my patients all my
family members this is a roller coaster
this is two steps forward one step back
this is alan's colleague a nurse he's
triple vaccinated but a lifelong asthma
patient
with all due respect this is one example
where a picture
doesn't actually do it justice no it
doesn't this is a picture where i was
like man i wish i had video
um
oh yeah you slow down well our producer
was in the room with the video camera
breathing i don't need anything else
he's activated anymore
i do wonder whether some people are
going to be like
put that camera down and pay attention
just like full-time nurse yeah well when
i'm doing that they're not my patients i
don't take pictures of my own patients
kim can you open your eyes for him 27
year old kim was an exception this is
kim she's such a unique person that she
was able to tolerate the ventilator and
not need a ton of sedation and so what
did she write on the board for you it
says i feel miserable here
tell us that you can hear us can you
squeeze our hand
so as that day went on
she ended up getting a little bit more
sick all right ready
one two three
and uh we ordered music therapy for her
you think kim's gonna make it
i think so she's just got like such a
spark of life i can't imagine
if she has anything to do with it
finally this is mr croxton he had the
heartstrings of about every nurse in our
unit i think when he was there
joel david croxton was 72 years old when
he died
this was the nurse who broke down after
she called his wife to tell her it was
time to come in and say goodbye
his wife sandy holding his hand
a nurse holding an ipad while a chaplain
prayed with him
this was the picture of croxton that
worried alan hawes
would it be too painful for his wife to
see
then again haws usually never sees the
families again
someone would like to see you
on this day they did
alan hawes saw sandy croxton again
how are you doing this time they just
held each other
no pictures needed
just thank you
to each other
i can only imagine how the front line
workers who are watching this piece are
saying he's telling our story thank you
alan hawes i think alan if he were here
at the table he'd say david you made
that all about me but the reality is i'm
doing this for them right it's
reflective of what all of us are going
through how is he holding on because
when you asked him is he broken you see
it on his face and he's seeing death and
sickness constantly
uh it's weighing on him he even said at
one point he goes we were so worried
about covert in the beginning but he
said we now are just you think you're
gonna get it you're kind of over it you
really don't worry about it
he's struggling really struggling i
thought it was interesting how he said
when they first come in and they're not
vaccinated he's a little angry with them
because look at it's a problem that you
cause for yourself and then you hear
your
stories honest and the empathy yeah
comes through here we are in year two of
the pandemic and we think we know these
stories david and you managed to refresh
the way we see it and we see it new it's
like it's the first time that's a
special talent you have we thank allen
hawes he was right when he called it a
public service announcement he said
that's what got him permission for a
year and a half he tried yeah thank you
david and thank you david